there is a group in Europe that seems
fundamentally unable to coexist with
greater Society the members of this
group are disproportionately violent as
indicated by crime statistics most cases
of vandalism can also be choked up to
them and if there is any violent crime
committed in your area and the members
of this group live there you can be
certain it was them it's time to break
the silence we need to talk openly about
this group under the general Behavior
namely men
now look I know what you're thinking
Adam I know and like plenty of men in my
life and they aren't all violent savages
the actions of some bad men shouldn't be
used to condemn the entire group to
which I say why don't you try living
around them probably before making your
cocked men's rights activist arguments
see how you'll like them after they stab
you in the throat for a cigarette or Rob
your house or beat you up for looking at
them wrong sometimes men even bend
together into large violent groups to
wreak havoc and burn down since
sometimes due to the most innocuous
things like their favorite football team
losing a match or something of course to
be fair some women also commit violent
crime and some of the most will damage
public property but just look at the
prison population 9 out of 10 violent
crime inmates or men now I'm not sexist
I myself have male friends I'm only
interested in making our communities
safer and The Logical solution to that
is to get rid of the group that's
responsible for all the violence
therefore I advocate for rounding up all
the men putting them in specific
residential areas within a city
preferably around the edge somewhere and
then building a wall to segregate them
from the rest of us to keep our city
safe from their criminal violent nature
right so the solutions you've just
listened to despite being absolutely
Preposterous would be an extremely
effective tool at curtailing violent
crime however we never hear it from the
crowd most obsessed with Law and Order
men as a group never seem to come up
despite being disproportionately violent
in the US the discussion always goes
back to black people and in Europe to
Roma people discrimination against Roma
and the ensuing socioeconomic problems
have been a constant theme in Central
and Eastern Europe for centuries at this
point and it really bothers me that many
of my fellow Europeans who claim to be
anti-racist and Progressive suddenly
turn into an SS officer when discussing
Roma
[Music]
thank you
and the situation of the Roma within
Europe really is dire casual racism and
sometimes openly genocidal rhetoric
towards them or fully accepted in many
places including within the European
Union in the year of Our Lord 2023
meanwhile entire Generations suffer and
get stuck at the Rock Bottom of society
in a vicious cycle where social problems
cause hatred and disdain which causes
more social problems which causes even
more hatred and so on and just ahead of
a criticism because I know it's coming
am I some shelter inner city liberal
[__] who has only seen pictures of Roma
from afar during his wide Guild classes
and who is now here to lecture the
silent majority suffering from violent
Roma crime about how evil and racist
they are and how Roma or misunders to
the angels no I grew up in Hungary
having lived a quarter of a century
there throughout the entire time I had
Roma's schoolmates friends and
acquaintances and lived in a
neighborhood that had drama inhabitants
I then moved to the Czech Republic where
I had drawn my neighbors and lived in
ustina for a while where most of the
czaroma minority is concentrated there I
also leave the rangroma encountering
them on a daily basis so if someone
wants to make the head try leaving a
random first and you'll see our Point
argument that's not going to work on me
sorry so first off who are the Roma the
are nomadic people who migrated to
Medieval Europe from Rajasthan India
through the Byzantine Empire perhaps due
to their Hindu cultural background
byzantians branded them as Heretics or
atigane a word which should sound
familiar to my Easter European viewers
as Roma moved into Europe their
reception was mixed countries in Eastern
Europe were generally tolerant of them
as long as they paid taxes in Western
Europe though their treatment range from
banishment to open genocide in England
they got hanged in France they got
branded in their head shaven in Bohemia
the right year of Roman women was cut
off in Moravia their left ear in Holland
they were legally slaughtered during
so-called hiding yachten or Heathen
hunts there was the great Gypsy Roundup
in 1749 Spain that saw thousands
arrested and hundreds dying in prison
but Eastern Europe wasn't a Haven of
equality either in Romania there was a
particularly gruesome Roma slave market
up until the 19th century as you can see
historically it hasn't been particularly
fun to be Roma in Europe later on with
the dawn of the Enlightenment Roma were
subjected to things like forced
assimilation prohibiting the use of
money languages under threat of violence
Banning marriage between Roma forcefully
taking Roma children from their parents
and giving them to non-normal families
and so on and of course when the Nazis
came to power Roma were the first to
suffer half a million were murdered but
after World War II Romo Holocaust
survivors were denied any reparations
even in the supposedly egalitarian and
leftist huge airports there Soviets fear
of influence they were ignored at best
otherwise they were often segregated
sometimes physically walled up from the
rest of society or worse in Soviet
Czechoslovakia for example there are
four sterilizations deportations
destructions of communities and so on a
particular example is the Czech town I
lived in usinatlabem it has a large Roma
Community many of them having Hungarian
surnames I found turns out they are the
descendants of Hungarian speaking Roma
from the south of Slovakia forcibly
deported by the Czechoslovakian
Communist party to the north of czechia
as cheap labor for the growing heavy
industry they worked the lowest jobs
received no training or education and
were moved into dilapidated abandoned
housing left behind by the deported
Sudan Germans after World War II so he
had a group of people mostly segregated
from in subpar housing doing the lowest
jobs with no further training or
education provided to them their
livelihoods solely depending on
unskilled labor in the local heavy
industry and that the Soviet Union
collabs taking the heavy industry with
it oops the result enormous rates of
poverty on mongroma bringing with it a
slew of socio-economic problems which
led to frictions within society which
led to more discrimination and hatred
which led to more socioeconomic problems
and the Vicious Cycle is complete a
particularly Vivid example of this is
the following in the city there was a
dilapidated residential block where
everyone lived famous for its social
problems after many complaints local
authorities finally got to work to solve
the issue by building a wall around them
in the year 1999 there was a big local
protest over it the whole Affair turned
into a minor International Scandal even
dubbing it the European Wall of Shame in
the end the war came down and the
residential units were vacated the
blocks stand there to this day abandoned
now then about segregation let's
consider that segregating main example
from the beginning I think we can all
agree that segregating older men is a
bad idea but some some of you might then
say men are more violent than women sure
but Roma men are especially more violent
and since males are necessary for the
continuation of the species it's easier
if you segregate based on ethnicity
instead of sex I.E the Roma are put into
the world of ghetto at the edge of town
and voila the city is safer now this is
a very common argument in Eastern Europe
but if you think about it for more than
a minute from a purely utilitarian
perspective it doesn't really make sense
if we're looking to decrease crime
especially violent crime then ethnicity
is not a good metric to go by in Eastern
European countries where most Roma live
there are plenty of non-roma criminals
too and the common denominator between
Roma and non-roma criminals is poverty
if you are poor and uneducated
statistically speaking you'll be far
more likely to commit a crime especially
violent crime so if our goal is to
decrease crime we should be talking
about segregating poor people not Roma
people but just like male segregation
the topic of poor segregation is also
not discussed the conversation always
goes back to Roma in Europe and black
people in America so the facts are clear
poor uneducated people commit more
crimes the majority of Aroma or poor and
uneducated but there are also millions
of poor uneducated non-roma I mean it's
eastern Europe are you kidding so if we
want to have less crime we should group
People based on wealth and education so
segregating poor uneducated people
anyone entered below the poverty line
and without a high school diploma goes
into the ghetto neatly welled up from
the rest of us and voila the city is
much safer now with all the poor is gone
and we can also agree that only an
absolute monster would suggest something
like that a deranged sociopath cruel ice
cold and unfeeling who would condemn
Millions to a life of Perpetual misery
in the ghetto in exchange for their own
perceived safety and comfort but
segregating the problem away also
doesn't work you're not solving the
underlying social problems you're just
putting the problem behind a wall and
then doing your best to forget about it
it's the equivalent of coming home
noticing that your bedroom is on fire so
you close the bedroom door and stop
using that part of your home and we all
see why that would be a subpar solution
so segregation besides not solving the
underlying problem would be a monstrous
act as we've agreed and I sure hope
segregation doesn't suddenly become okay
when it comes to Roma people well stay
tuned as monstrous as it is segregating
based on wealth is actually more
defensible than segregating based on
ethnicity since being poor is something
you can theoretically change about
yourself unlike your ethnicity therefore
logically if segregating poor people is
viewed as a monster's act then
segregating Roma people should be
perceived as outright diabolical right
right but it's not [__] over Roma is
socially accepted sometimes even
expected throughout Eastern Europe
usually with the full support of the
state by the way okay but then how come
Roma can't just get their own [__]
together and prove to society that they
can indeed integrate why don't Roma just
Escape their property in this
meritocratic free market to answer this
question I've talked to bogler fedorco
the director of Romo versitas a
Hungarian organization dedicated to
helping Roma students overcome the
effects of systemic racism and help them
achieve an education there is a lot of
disadvantages uh not because Roma are
culturally inferior and don't want to
learn and are incapable of learning
which a lot of politicians and the
majority society would like to us to
believe uh but because in European
societies Roma lived in deep poverty in
the most cases so according to the
latest research 80 of the Roma
population in Europe lives below the
poverty line so poverty you know makes
it very difficult to obtain quality
education and participate successfully
in education because if you don't have a
table to write your homework uh on you
know that's again a big obstacle if your
parents are unable to help you with your
homework that's a huge obstacle
so already in the primary school uh
those Roma kids who who are coming from
poverty they acquire a lot of
disadvantages
um and even though there are some who
are not coming from uh you know deep
poverty they also face racism
um so that is starting very early on in
the Hungarian education system and this
uh you know viewing the Roma's other the
non-deserving this also manifests in the
practice of segregation on top of all
this some Eastern European governments
are actively involved in discriminating
against Roma I've made a community post
about a recent occasion where thousands
of Ukrainian rumors arrived at Prague
main station fleeing the war they did
not get any Aid or services for refugees
as the Czech government insisted that
they all have Hungary and citizenships
they were Hungarian speaking you see as
Ukrainian Hungarian dual citizens they
wouldn't be eligible for Refugee status
and should be sent back to Hungary by
train instead which Hungary refused
however hundreds of Roma were Milling
around the station and thousands in the
city for weeks until check public
television revealed that the authorities
already vetted 5 500 of them and that
only 150 of them had Hungary and
passports and the Czech government kept
this information secret for weeks hoping
that Hungary would cave under diplomatic
pressure in the meantime so they can get
rid of those refugees instead of helping
them because they are Roma moreover in
the Czech Republic's second largest city
Bruno the authorities straight up stated
that they won't be helping Roman
refugees from Ukraine because they lie
cheat steal and abuse the system none of
this was substantiated by any evidence
by the way I guess the Bruno City
leadership just had a feeling that this
was the case anyway but sometimes
governments go even further in Hungary
there was a scandal about school
segregation in the town of jingershpata
in the local elementary school all Roma
students were put on the ground floor
while white students were put on the
upper floors Roma students were banned
from going upstairs and they couldn't
even use the bathrooms there they were
also banned from after-school study
groups and swimming classes and received
vastly inferior education
invisible
Network
[Music]
foreign
because of these measures Roman children
could not be accepted into quality
higher education and got stuck at the
bottom flunked out of school later on
and so on the end result more poverty
and more social problems now to this
proponents of segregation usually
respond with the following you are only
against segregating Roma because you
haven't gone to school with them Roma
children are very problematic and ruin
education for everyone else but here's
why this argument doesn't make any sense
if the problem is problematic children
why not put problematic kids into
different classes instead of Roma kids
take a class of say 30 kids 15 of them
Roma the other 15 aren't Roma kids
generally come from worst socioeconomic
backgrounds so more of our kids will be
problematic sure so we have 10
problematic Roma kids and three
problematic non-roma kids we segregate
them based on ethnicity and would you
look at that both classes ended up with
problematic children hindering everyone
else's education whereas if we organize
them based on who's problematic we get a
class of both Roma and non-roma but
without any problematic kids hindering
their education and the other class of
problem with the kids shouldn't be just
shoved into the lower levels either they
should get the help they need to
compensate for their issues you know one
of the fundamental tasks of the
education system but we never hear the
solution from proponents of ethnic
segregation this might come as a shock
to everyone but their problem is not
with their kids having to study with
problematic kids it's having to study
with Roma kids it's just fear Prejudice
and disgust at the end of the day but
they're cutting the tree under
themselves you see segregated schools
just Doom another generation Aroma kids
to a life without opportunity proper
education and the ability to make more
than the minimum wage if that which only
results in more crime and social
problems case in point according to Romo
versitas they never had a single Roma
student preparing for higher education
who came from a segregated school back
to Ginger spot or Hungary the family is
affected in the school segregation case
sued the government and won a quarter of
a million euros as a compensation but
then the Hungarian prime minister Victor
Orban intervened personally to stop the
payout calling it money for nothing that
the victims didn't have to work for and
said that the shorosh network is behind
the Court ruling so in 2020 to we
basically come to a point where almost
half of the you know young Roma children
go to segregated schools and you know
segregation is not only outlawed legally
but is also uh leads to receiving very
low quality education in the Hungarian
school system which is anyhow you know
like crumbling as we speak so in the
whole nation there is protest by
teachers and students and this is
usually led by those who go to Elite
high schools and those who teach in
early Thai schools in big cities or in
the capital in Budapest but this is
Multiplied when it when it comes to roma
roma students the Vicious Cycle the Roma
find themselves in is quite clear but
then what's the solution here the usual
responses that Roman people just need to
get their [__] together and prove to the
rest of society that they can coexist as
equals if a Roman person wants to
succeed surely they can in today's
meritocratic world can't they surely
they aren't being held back in almost
every aspect of life or they so everyday
discrimination manifests in you know
basically all spheres of Life uh so in
housing in education which I just talked
about in employment in healthcare in
whatever uh sphere of life you can
imagine Roma face racism and
discrimination on an everyday basis I
think uh what is the increasing as a
form as a as you know a presence type of
discrimination is a discrimination in
housing so many people can't imagine
that they you know Turn Up For a viewing
of a house which they would like to rent
and then they are outright told that
sorry the the apartment has been leased
to someone else this what happens in my
experience and also there is some
research around this 90 of the cases
when Roma to be tenants you know Turn Up
For a viewing or they are already
rejected you know based on their
surnames based on on how they speak in
the phone setting up of an interview you
know not to talk about the inability
financially to rent these apartments
even if they are able financially they
you know get to a point where they are
able to rent financially which is not
hard not easy because there is a lot of
discrimination in employment as well
they basically can't rent on an
appointment and of course in you know
every kind of situation you might face
discrimination and it might be very
direct you know being told in your face
that sorry we don't accept Roma people
here but it can be you know just like
more subtle forms of racism that oh
sorry this job vacancy has been filled
ever since you applied and you know it's
it's very hard to navigate this system
where you don't know you know what
you're allowed to do and what you can't
basically being Roma is like living life
on Hardcore difficulty most people will
dislike or even hate you before you even
open your mouth Baseline services and
amenities are suddenly not available
available to you want to move out of the
ghetto get a normal job and send your
kids to a good school too bad nobody
will rent their apartment to you all the
jobs you apply for are suddenly taken
and your kids are automatically barged
from the good school and there are also
the everyday things like if you want to
go have fun they often won't let you
into clubs and bars security guards and
stores will follow you around thinking
you're a thief and so on and so forth
and then we wonder why Romo can't escape
their predicament so what can we do to
help solve this situation it's not an
easy question to answer uh because you
know we are talking about systemic
racism and discrimination against Roma
in in Hungary and all across the world
so you might you know consider
individual actions that but they might
not lead a long way that's why I believe
that you know on the long term we need
political leadership that is taking this
issue very seriously and implements
concrete actions to tackle racism
against Roma so uh be sure to you know
vote for those political parties who
have an extensive and ambitious
political program that supports
minorities including Roma and these
programs should have been you know built
together with the constituences so Roma
people in this case so look out for you
know this whether these programs are
ambitious enough and they were uh
including Roma you know experts and roma
people into their formulation hold you
know your politicians accountable uh not
just you know the present ones but those
who you would like to support to be in
power in the longer term you can also
take like very effective and impactful
and important you know direct actions in
your daily life so I would say first
educate yourself you know investigate
how you feel and think about Roma
because you know it's most likely that
you've never learned you know a single
history lesson about them
um and while you you know through
education popular culture you discovered
that you know like you support black
people you support other minorities you
support LGBT people and it's kind of
like you know something that you know we
take for prevented that a lot of you
know people in society are aware of you
know black people's cars are aware of
you know migrants cause a lot of people
are not aware of the Roma cause at all
and of course if you are in any kind of
like power holder situation so if you
are a company owner then have um
anti-discrimination policy which is
strictly enforced and break together
with drama organizations uh so that they
that you can recruit Roma Talent as well
and you specifically reach out to them
be you know very direct in formulating
that you support members of oppressed
communities minorities to apply for a
position and that you won't discriminate
them and be thorough in your
investigation whether you're already
have some practices which are exclusive
uh discriminatory to some if you're a
school principal be you know sure that
you imply and apply policies that are
inclusive to Roma so you know have a
policy that's Roma kids who come to your
school will be you know granted access
because this is what happens a lot of
times that you know only the local uh
you know wealthier families can send
their children to your school to a
district school and for some reason Roma
will be rejected
so be very precise in formulating that
you know all kids are welcome in this
school and be precise in enforcing this
policy and of course I could go on and
on and on in you know by tailoring this
message to different life circumstances
and positions but I hope you got the
message at the end of the day it all
comes down to becoming aware of the
situation with rumor and on an
individual level making sure to not make
the situation any worse for them solving
the problems affecting Roma is in our
common interest as a society and it's
not that difficult actually when
Hungarian speaking rumor fled the war in
Ukraine Hungarian volunteers actually
took the time and effort to create
proper well-resourced educational
daycare programs for Roma children and
surprise surprise they really
appreciated it and they started
improving dramatically often for the
first time in their lives they were
getting close attention from teachers
and their quality education they went
from Little gypsies to just children
learning playing enjoying their life if
you want more like this to happen do
look up what kind of local charities
there are in your area helping Roma like
Roma versus Hungary whose donation page
is linked in the description integration
is fully possible in any society not
outright hostile against them and that
hostility can be dispelled with Time by
spreading awareness by exposing people
to positive examples of the ethnic group
and for the time being through the work
of non-governmental organizations the
Irish were once in the same situation
viewed as inherently inferior criminal
low IQ troublemaking degenerates due to
their impoverished background in the US
they were called White n-words in fact
racism against the Irish is something
Unthinkable and this already happened
with Roma in Spain where since the great
Gypsy Roundup of the 18th century
Spanish Society just sort of chilled out
and now Roma are just another part of
them between 750 000 and 1.5 million of
them seamlessly integrated into Spanish
society and this is the future I want
for the rest of Europe as well trust me
we will all be better off for it